support for Europe is at its highest in
35 years as 67 percent of citizens
believe their country benefits from EU
membership and for the first time in the
last 10 years the majority of them think
their voice counts in Europe if you want
more democracy and we need more
democracy we need to strengthen the
European Parliament we are defending our
values inside the outside European Union
across the EU citizens have made it
clear what's most important to them
beginning with democracy half of
Europeans are interested in EU elections
and almost one-third know the date of
next year's vote
nearly half of people surveyed say the
lead candidate process which gives them
a say and who will become the Commission
President motivates them to vote again
over 60% of citizens believe this
process makes the EU more transparent
and democratic terrorism youth
unemployment and immigration topped the
list of priorities citizens want the EU
to address economic prosperity the fight
against climate change and human rights
are also important so what's the biggest
challenge for the EU citizens plays
greater importance on national rather
than European elections even though
voting is seen as a civic duty and a way
to bring about change
the EU has its work cut out in order to
get people to the polls
[Music]